[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY
EVERYBODY.
SO MY THE ONLY GUY WHO'S BEEN IN
A GREAT MOOD SINCE THE MIDTERMS?
I LIKE TO THANK DR. SIEGEL.
BUT ALSO I'M ALSO A SILVER
LINING SCOTT SEARCY RIGHT NOW
I'M WEARING A MADE OF PURE
SILVER.
IT WAS A CHRISTMAS GIFT FROM
WILLIAM TO VEIN.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW YOU KNOW IT'S IN MY SAFE.
IT APPEARS THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WILL TAKE THE HOUSE, AND LIKE I
SAID LAST NIGHT --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU.
I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT BUT
I'LL TAKE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
LIKE I SAID KEEP THE HOUSE, YOU
KEEP THE PEACE.
SO WE SHOULD START THING ABOUT
ALL THE COOL BELIEVE WE CAN DO
NOW THAT WE'VE THE PLACE TO
OURSELVES.
I'D FIRST: THE EXTERMINATORS TO
KILL ANYTHING THE PREVIOUS
TENANTS LEFT BEHIND.
[LAUGHTER]
I ESPECIALLY WANT TO FUMIGATE
JERRY ADLER'S PANTS.
I KNOW WHAT IS IN THERE?
SO MANY THINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, IF HIS LINING COULD TALK.
LET'S GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
HUNTER'S LAPTOP.
OR MAYBE NOT THE BOTTOM, BECAUSE
WHO KNOWS WHERE THAT'S BEEN
POSTMARKED HUNTER AS THE FIRST
LAPTOP THAT HAD A VIRUS THAT
ACTUALLY NEEDED PENICILLIN TO
KILL.
AND WHOEVER GOES TO THE HARD
DRIVE WILL NEED EXTRA GLOVES,
DOUBLE MASKS, AND HOLY WATER.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THE FEDS
BELIEVED THAT THERE WAS ENOUGH
EVIDENCE TO CHARGE MY TAX
CRIMES, AND LYING ABOUT DRUG USE
WHEN HE BOUGHT A HANDGUN IN
2018.
HE'S PRETTY SURE THAT HE BOUGHT
IT ON DRUGS BECAUSE HE FILLED IT
WITH THE BLUE CRAYON AND PIG
LATIN.
WITH THE G.O.P. HOUSE MAJORITY
IS TIME TO EXCAVATE VERY, VERY
LAPTOP STORY IN ALL ITS GLORY.
IN A MATTER HOW MUCH THE MEDIA
TRIES TO IGNORE IT LIKE IT DID
THE FIRST TIME AROUND WE CANNOT
FORCE THEIR HAND AND GO WHERE
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO.
JUST LIKE HUNTER DID WITH THE
HORSE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE TELEPROMPTER SAID.
>> Tyrus: JUST A WHOLE NEW
GREG.
>> Greg: I'M IN A REALLY BAD
MOOD.
IT'S NOT ABOUT HUNTER THE BIG
GUY.
HE WASN'T AWARE OF HIS SONS
FEELINGS THAT'S FINE AFTER ALL
THEY'RE NOT AWARE THAT HE IS IN
THE LADIES ROOM IN THE SINK.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT WHO ARE WE KIDDING QUESTION
WHERE JOE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON
RIGHT JOE?
>> NO, NO, NO YOU CANNOT LOOK
BACK.
YOU CAN'T LOOK BACK.
A WISE MAN ONCE SAID DON'T LOOK
BACK YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE WHAT YOU
SEE.
YOU KNOW WHO SAID THAT?
THAT WAS MARK TWAIN.
OR MAYBE CORN POP.
ONE OF THOSE GUYS.
BUT NO I CAN'T LOOK BACK, I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING
IN 2019.
I CAN'T MEMBER WHAT I HAD FOR
BREAKFAST.
I'LL TAKE WHAT I DIDN'T HAVE FOR
BREAKFAST, MALARKEY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I ALSO, I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO GET TO KNOW THE 51 INTEL
AGENTS WHO SIGNED THAT LETTER
SAYING THAT HUNTER'S LAPTOP WAS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
A CLAIM SO LAUGHABLE IT MADE
VLADIMIR PUTIN SHAKE WITH
LAUGHTER AND NOT WITH
PARKINSON'S.
I WANT REPUBLICANS ASKING THE
QUESTIONS, NO GRANDSTANDING, NO
OVERPRODUCED LOOP JANUARY 6TH.
[LAUGHTER]
I WANT TO KNOW HOW GOVERNMENT
INTEL AGENCIES COULD SO HAPPILY
LEND THEMSELVES TO ALLY AND WANT
TO SEE THE EMAILS BETWEEN THE
TECH PLATFORM, THE MEDIA, AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
I BUT IS MORE INCESTUOUS THAN
THE ROYAL FAMILY.
WHAT?
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP, I DIDN'T BUT
I'M SURE IT'S THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHS]
>> Tyrus: OR YOU COULD JUST
LOOK.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: OR YOU COULD JUST
LOOK.
A G.O.P. HOUSE SHIMMING CLEANING
HOUSE MAYBE THE INCOMPETENT ACTS
TREAT THEM LIKE ON IT IF THERE'S
ENOUGH LYSOL ON THE PLANET TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT, BUT TED CRUZ
ALREADY SAID IT IT'S TIME TO
BLEACH THE ORCHIDS.
YOU REMEMBER HIM.
HE IS THE DHS SECRETARY WHO HUNG
HIS OWN AGENTS TO DRY OVER
MITIGATE.
HOW DO YOU SAY WHAT A BEACH IN
SPANISH?
THIS IS WHAT I WISH GERALDO WAS
HERE.
THAT FAMOUS PICTURE THAT
SUPPORTS ELISE O'DEA BORDER
AGENTS WHIPPING MIGRANTS THEY
KNEW IT WAS B.S. BUT HE WANTED
TV ANYWAY AND SAID THEY WERE.
AND THE PRESIDENT FOLLOWED SUIT
SAYING THOSE GUYS WERE PAID.
IT SOUNDS A GREAT MESSAGE TO OUR
REPORTER AGENTS SURE IT'S A
DANGEROUS AND THANKLESS JOB, BUT
AT LEAST WE WILL SCREW YOU OVER
TOO.
PLENTY OF OTHER INJURIES.
AND SURE HE NEVER GET CONVICTED
BY THE SENATE BUT SO WHAT IT
WOULD SEND A MESSAGE THAT
AMERICANS ARE CAN LET THAT STUFF
SLIDE.
FINALLY THE BIG ONE.
MAYBE WE CAN FIND THE PUSH FOR
THE TRUTH ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
COVID-19.
DID IT COME FROM THE WUHAN LAB?
OR A DIRTY BUTTER KNIFE AT THE
AURORA IHOP?
[LAUGHTER]
OR WAS IT THE BOND WATER FROM
KAT'S OFFICE?
[LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHS]
IT FEELS LIKE IT'S SOMETHING HE
WANTS US TO FORGET ABOUT YOU
KNOW LIKE HE DOES WITH HIS PANTS
WHEN HE'S HEADING DOWN TO THE
OVAL OFFICE.
AS GRAYBILL SHAKESPEARE ONCE
SAID.
IT SOUNDED BETTER IN THE KINGS
ANGUISH BUT YOU GET THE MEANING.
ACCORDING TO A POLL I MADE UP OF
MY HEAD JUST NOW MOST AMERICANS
ARE IN AGREEMENT THAT SOMEONE OR
SOMETHING SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE OR I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE SOMEONE WHOSE LAST NAME
RHYMES WITH GROUCHY?
OR SOME COUNTRY.
I JUST SPITBALLING HIM.
BUT MILLIONS DIED IN EXPERT
SLIDE, AND NO ONE IS GETTING
FRIED WE BOMBED COUNTRIES FOR
LESS.
AND YET HERE WE ARE COMING UP ON
THREE YEARS LATER JUST LIKE
TRUFFLE FRIES WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHERE KOBE CAME FROM.
BUT WE ARE SEEING THE LONG-TERM
CONSEQUENCES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THINGS ALSO IMPART TO
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME GO ASK A
FIFTH-GRADER IF HE KNOWS HOW TO
DO LONG DIVISION QUESTION WORK
HE WON'T WHICH IS WHY A FIRE AT
HIM ACCOUNTANT.
THAT ANY GOT HOT CHOCOLATE ON MY
W9.
THE GEO PAGE SHOULD VIEW TUESDAY
IS A CHANCE TO BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SANITY BACK
TO GOVERNMENT.
ALSO IT'LL JUST BE FUN AS TO
WATCH.
AND FRANKLY WE HAVE EARNED IT.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TENNITES GUESTS.
HE IS THE REASON CRAVINGS ARE
CALLED JOAN SINGH,
LAWRENCE JONES, SORRY ON
SATURDAY NIGHTS LAWRENCE JONES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AS A WRESTLER HE RAISED CANE AS
MAYOR HE IS LOWERING THE BOOM.
WWE WRESTLER GLENN JACOBS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS BONE YEAR THAN THE MUSEUM
OF NATURAL HISTORY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND NO ONE'S EVER GIVEN HIM A
BAG OVER RATING.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK TYRUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
MAYOR JACOBS CONGRATULATIONS ON
BEING THE FIRST PERSON BE TALLER
THAN TYRUS ON THE SHOW.
>> Glenn: ARE ALL BIG GUYS,
BUT APPARENTLY DOES ONLY ONE BIG
GUY.
YOU SEE HOW HE ACTUALLY ROLLS IS
IN IT?
>> Greg: I WANT TO ASK YOU IF
YOU COULD PICK THE
INVESTIGATIONS WHICH ONE WOULD
BE OF INTEREST TO YOU?
>> Glenn: I CANNOT WAIT TO SEE
RON PAUL.
FINALLY TAKEN THE GLOVES ALL THE
WAY OFF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID MR. I AM THE
SCIENCE, HE CRUSHED ANY
SENTIMENT EVEN FROM CREDIBLE
SOURCES.
THE LOCKDOWNS WERE THE WORST
PUBLIC POLICY MISTAKE THIS
COUNTRY IS EVER MADE SHRED OF
THE CONSTITUTION, DESTROYED,
HURT PEOPLE.
THE TITLE I AMNESTY FOR COVID,
COVID AMNESTY THEY NEED TO BE
TALK ABOUT COVID, COVERT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Greg: A LOT OF SEES.
ALSO, IF YOU'RE STILL DOING GAIN
OF FUNCTION.
RIGHT?
WHICH A STUDY JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO OR SO MY QUESTION I CAN
REMEMBER I WAS HIGH.
BUT YOU GET MY POINT.
THAT'S CRAZY.
LAWRENCE.
WHISTLING WRONG WITH ME?
NOTE I GOT A PUPPY AND IT'S MAKE
HIM ANGRY ALL TIME.
[LAUGHS]
IT SUPPOSED TO BE THE OPPOSITE
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE I'M UP
AT 6:00 A.M., I'M NEVER UP
UNLESS I'M COMING HOME.
[LAUGHS]
ANYWAY.
ALL THE KIDS JOKES COMING BACK.
[LAUGHS]
WHAT YOU THINK LAWRENCE ON WITH
THIS ANYMORE.
[LAUGHS]
'S BEFORE I GOT A LOT TO SAY.
SO LOOK, I AGREE I PARTIALLY
AGREE WITH THE MONOLOGUE BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO FEEL GOOD THEY
TORTURED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SO IT'S HUMAN NATURE YOU WANT
RETALIATION.
THAT IS WHO WE ARE AND WHAT SAYS
THEY DON'T RETALIATION JUST
LYING TO THEMSELVES.
THE PROBLEM IS I FEEL LIKE IT'S
NOT CAN ENCOMPASS ANYTHING I
DON'T GO TO JAIL.
I WANT PEOPLE TO GO TO JAIL
ACTUALLY.
RIGHT?
I'M TIRED OF CRIMINALS JUST
WALKING THE STREET, THE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, THE B.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS ARE
UNIQUE POSITION ITALY DEFENSE.
THAT IS STOPPING THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NOT TO DO ANYMORE
DAMAGE ON PEOPLE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN DEMOCRATS COME
UP WITH REPUBLICANS, EVERYONE IS
JUST PISTOL OFF.
WILL THE DOING SO WHAT CAN I DO?
GO OFF AFTER THE IRS AGENTS.
WE DID WE STOPPED AT IN THE WAY
YOU DO IT YOU COULD HIRE THEM,
BUT THEY WON'T GET A PAYCHECK I
GUARANTEE THAT THEY QUIT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU DO THAT, ALSO THE FBI AGENTS
OF THE OTHER ONES WERE JUST
BUYING GO AFTER THEM.
MAKE SURE THEY GET NO FUNDING.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE GONNA HAVE
THE PEN OF THE PURSE, THAT'S HOW
YOU UNDO THESE BAD IDEAS,
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WHEN IT COMES
TO LABELS AS THEY WANT YOU TO
FUND THESE THREE IDEAS THAT THEY
HAVE.
THAT WE HAVE TO PAY FOR.
SO I THINK IT SHOULD BE ABOUT AS
MUCH SOMEONE AGREE WITH YOU GREG
I THINK THE INVESTIGATION NEEDS
TO HAPPEN, BUT WANT TO BE ASKED
TO TRUE POWER.
>> Greg: OH GET THEM OFF THE
SHOW, AGREE WITH ME.
I AGREE ME.
WHO CARES IF THERE IS NO
PROGRESS?
WHO CARES IF THERE ARE NO
RESULTS QUESTION RIGHT IT'LL BE
FUN AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT ON THE
SHOW EVERY NIGHT.
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE
ESPECIALLY IF YOUR BOND WATER
JOKE.
REALLY GOOD.
GREAT JOB.
[LAUGHS]
NO, I DON'T KNOW WHY IT DOES NOT
MORE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SEE
COVID BE INVESTIGATED.
IT'S REALLY ABSURD THAT A
STOPPING A SOPPING INVESTIGATED.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE IF YOU HAVE
THAT FRIEND YOU CAN GO OUT WITH
AND THEY GET SUPER HAMMERED AT
THE DISASTER OF A NIGHT AND THEN
THEY HIT YOU UP LIKE HALEY DOING
THIS WEEKEND?
AND YOU LIKE, YOU'RE NOT OUTSIDE
ABOUT HOW YOU THREW UP ON THE
DANCE FLOOR?
AND I LIKE JAN MUST'VE BEEN THAT
BAD SUPER 8.
COULD HAPPEN ANYONE, NO I SAY TO
15 SHOTS.
I'LL MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT CAN
EASILY HAPPEN AGAIN.
THERE REALLY SUCK FOR ME.
I DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO BE THE
REAL PROBLEMS LIKE I DIDN'T DIE
NO I KNOW DIED OUR KIDS OUT TO
BE AT HOME WITH.
SLICK FOR THE PEOPLE TO HAVE
THOSE PROBLEMS IT'S WAY WORSE.
>> Greg: I KNOW PEOPLE WHO
DIED FROM IT.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HAVE
BEEN PREMIER LI FROM IT.
I REALLY CARE IF IT'S OUR FAULT,
IF IT'S AMERICAN'S FAULT.
ON A CARE YET OUT.
>> Tyrus: FIRST OF ALL I SAID
SEVERAL TIMES FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE BORDER NEED TO
BE HELD COUNTABLE.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT EVEN RIGHT
NOW THOSE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
STILL PENDING PUNISHMENT SO THEY
STILL HAVE IT OVER THEIR HEAD.
THERE AND HAVE SOME FINE, SOME
SUSPENSE.
IT'S THAT SITTING OVER TOP YOUR
HEAD NOT TO MENTION WAS THE
APOLOGY?
IF YOU LIVE IN THE CITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS OF PEOPLE SAY KNOW
THIS, THE VET.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE AND KAT, I
DISAGREE AS I LOOK AT COVID LIKE
I WAS IN A BAD MARRIAGE.
AND WHEN SHE LEFT THE LAST THING
I WANTED WOULD BE TO GO TO
THERAPY AND TALK ABOUT WHY
DIDN'T HELP.
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE FREE I DON'T
WANT TO SEE HER ANYMORE, I DON'T
WANT TO TALK IT WASN'T YOU IT
WAS ME.
I'M FINE WITH IT.
MANY GO OUTSIDE AND ENJOY THE
SUN YOU JUST BE MISERABLE IT'S
FINE.
IT'S ME.
>> Kat: JUST TO CLARIFY IT
COULD BE GOOD FOR YOU TO GO TO
INDIVIDUAL THERAPY TO MAKE SURE
YOU DON'T END UP IN A MARRIAGE
LIKE THAT AGAIN?
>> Tyrus: THE NEXT TIME I SEE
THAT I JUST GO THE OTHER WAY.
>> Kat: ARE YOU SURE?
[LAUGHS]
HISTORY CAN REPEAT ITSELF.
>> Tyrus: I'M HAPPILY MARRIED
BY THE WAY.
OH ABSOLUTELY.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: NONE OF THIS IS REAL.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE IF I'M HERE
RIGHT NOW.
I JUST COULD BE A BAD DREAM
HAVING.
HAPPY FACE THAT'S THE REAL
PROBLEM LAWRENCE.
ALL RIGHT THAT WAS SARCASTIC
JO